ladies of London star Julie Montagu is
an American living in British
aristocracy but she's also a yogi and a
health nut so who better to teach us
some recipes perfect for a royal wedding
watch party on spilling the royal tea
[Music]
all right Miss Julie Montagu from rural
Illinois to a country manor in England
you married the Earl of Sandwich what
does that make your title well okay
technically I married the future Earl of
Sandwich that will make me eventually on
the Countess of sandwich so yes I am
here with the Countess of sandwich you
guys you know kind of Megan Marco before
Megan Markel was Megan Markel an
American marrying into British
aristocracy thought you know huh Megan
she's very happy she's very Californian
super healthy so I had to make something
that you could eat and still feel good
about yourself as you're watching the
Royal Wedding alright so in honor of
Megan and the Royal Wedding let's make
some healthy treats great you have come
up with this cocktail for us I love the
name should we say it together yeah the
royalty Kela oh my god brilliant
Earl Grey tea because we're British
tequila Bianca Earl connection
[Music]
so let's go over the ingredients here I
wanted I want a spot like this because I
made this the Cressida I tried to buy
simple syrup and I googled it and it's
just easier to make it yourself sugar
and water boil together Wow amazing
we're gonna squeeze a lemon so we're
gonna squeeze a lemon in our squeeze
earth that it's gonna be ingredient
number one Kiera's are totally ready to
go mmm smelling good Earl Grey tea which
I nice Starbucks you don't want to bring
your own t-mobile order to Earl Grey tea
and then we've got the G key right here
and then we're just gonna put in like a
couple tables tablespoon of the your
special simple syrup and then we're
gonna shake it all up pour it into some
glasses and then I mean it's gonna take
a little bit of this sort of orange peel
I'm just gonna basically peel it off
okay
and that's gonna garnish it it's just a
little garnish garnish this is so easy
thank you for being such an easy sexy
little drink perfect for you aren't even
name is beyond so I'm going to start
with pouring tequila things okay because
that's my skill set okay and you peel
the orange because I don't know anything
about how to do even the Simpson we're
just gonna get this lovely orange peel
and then we can stick it in each of our
glasses right um
okay great so you're doing tequila
excellent shots so we want to get here
well it's up to you how are you feeling
well it's 10:00 a.m. I mean it is the
world like what time is it in London
okay time for a drink in London so we're
fine okay got four shots fish
let's get that lemon squeezed in got a
squeezer okay other way there we go
there we go while we're doing this talk
to me tell me about um her food drink
changes she's going to experience
shooters gonna have elevenses well
technically that's what we're having now
is it's almost 11 o'clock isn't it is
that happy hour in England kind of when
you go shooting elevenses oh yeah it's
brunch so there we go serve right branch
so we're happy so she'll have elevenses
okay let's get
this cancer and my simple okay we're
gonna shake this go like Megan's shaken
up our life in a new country with the
new word new accent okay here we go I'm
ready okay I've got the orange peel look
good I love by the way tea I feel for
drinks is very entrenched oh isn't it
okay
we've garnished with a little orange
peel I love it Cheers
that's so good
I am scared because I know how much
tequila is in this and I'm really not
tasting it Julie isn't it Julie your
ladies of London days I'm Brad I know
they're over but this is a new chapter
that you need to drink during those days
yeah mm-hmm I did it was always offset
so my dear future Countess of sandwich
North leather sandwiches love that
sandwiches at teeth you have come up
with for us a beautiful open-faced
sandwich that would be perfect for a
royal wedding yeah party yes exactly
okay now it's perfect because a it's
it's the royal wedding but B let's
remember that Megan is super healthy
health conscious so this is all healthy
but delicious so we're gonna use wheat
and gluten-free bread which is from be
free which is filled with like all
things good and a lotta fiber
[Music]
I call this my mindfulness fight so I
want everybody to be mindful while
they're watching the Royal Wedding and
then it goes back to my book recharge be
mindful and what you're doing it's mine
and eating the sandwich okay so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna spread a
half avocado on here so do we want to
mash it up sure let's mask a little bit
take that off and then I'm so easy I
love you by the way for making this it's
so easy and simple you guys I got all of
these ingredients just at a local
grocery store Brad half an avocado then
we're gonna take some smoked salmon and
we're just gonna plonk that on there
then I'm gonna take just some beet and
again you can just buy the cooked beets
right a beet is a beet as it beats
thanks for saying that because that's
what I did I didn't want to tell you
that's okay then we're gonna sprinkle
cashew nuts so look at we got avocado or
a healthy omega-3 fatty acids are
healthy fat we've got salmon which has
tryptophan in it which helps really with
the production of serotonin and
serotonin makes us all feel really good
and then we've got beets high in
antioxidants look at that red color and
then cashew nuts our protein and then
basically just to make it extra super
delicious we're gonna squeeze some lemon
juice okay we squeeze the lemons I know
about the lemons are you happy we're
doing pink Himalayan sea salt mm-hmm
we're about not sure it got me the best
ingredients I know you were bringing
that bread that is just everybody it's
gonna be on another level no it's been
great
yes let's give it a little a little
camera love this is gorgeous it's soaked
there we go
it's so pretty and like you said so many
great ingredients and easy and people
will be so impressed at your Royal
Wedding ranch party and they'll feel
good no bloating all that stuff after
eating this they're gonna feel energized
and mindful because when we're looking
at beautiful yoga doing Meghan we want
to feel harassed yes yeah exactly
oh my gosh Julie that was we physically
made all of that in under 10 minutes
we did but wave for sure on the drink
aimed the sandwich in undertown I'm all
about fast quick easy I've got four kids
I gotta be like you've got a recharge
tell us a couple of your other amazing
food based books that people can buy
yeah so I have two cookbooks out called
superfoods and then one called superfood
super fast so people like me new horse
super busy they can make wheat the book
makes recipes my recipes in 20 minutes
or less
and they're energizing so similar to
this Julie thank you so much for doing
this so fun Julie Montagu everybody
thank you for being here for spilling
the royalty Kela with us everybody
follow Julie on social media and of
course you can check out both of us
covering the Royal Wedding oh that's
right sugar have you should we double
uh-huh be perfect loved it
[Music]